Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 111th episode!
1-1-1!
BAU BAU!
Not 1-1-1, it's BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I hope that you got a good sleep.
And if you didn't, I hope you had a bunch of fun!
Hopefully together with us.
BAU BAU!
I love oar.
Yeah, I love oar.
For Ruffians who are joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Today's the Monday, right?
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Okay, if you thought that
I don't know what day it is.
Hashtag, hashtag.
You tell FUWAMOCO Morning what day of the week it is!
It's Monday.
I was just testing Moco-chan.
I said, do I have a pup talk today?
Do I have a pup talk today?
Because I don't know!
It's a Monday.
We're gonna start off the week very specially because it's our first anniversary.
We're gonna start the week off on the right paw all together.
We're gonna make it a super fun one regardless of whether it's the weekday or the weekend.
It's a big week!
BAU BAU!
Our first anniversary!
This isn't the very first FUWAMOCO Morning.
Not the day the very first FUWAMOCO Morning happened.
Not yet.
Soon though.
Soon!
Wow!
Oh!
It's a big week!
But that doesn't mean that there isn't difficulties.
Yeah.
If any week comes difficulties, right?
You know, there's been... Another Pero Sighting.
Difficulties like that, huh?
What kind of nastiness is he getting into now, huh?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Is this nasty?
Yeah, this looks like the best peron.
No.
Why?
Right?
Good.
Good, yeah.
Good is right, yeah.
No.
Yeah.
Rest in peace, peron.
No, this is good.
This is the best peron.
Yeah.
His nastiness is just getting roasted.
Right.
It's becoming all gooey and sweet.
Yeah, it's perfect.
Yeah, you know his tune sort of changes when you have him skewered on a stick over a fire, huh?
Right.
Yeah.
I think that happens, right?
Look at him there!
Save him!
I think you mean eat him.
I wanna bite.
I wanna bite too.
Right!
I much, much prefer this peron.
Can't say anything nasty at all.
He's burning.
Yeah.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Fire Fire like the Pero.
A bit of a different song, but sounds good.
Pero oishii yone!
Oishii yone!
Nakami ga torotoyo!
Right?
The taste though, I'm pretty sure.
You have to spit out the two balls in the butt.
Right.
It's just like the, you know, the pit of the cherry.
Personality's nasty, but the flavor... Flavor?
Quite roasty.
Yeah.
Yeah, but Ruffians!
Remember this one, okay?
This is what we should all strive to achieve if we ever see Pero while we're out and about, okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
We hope you had a great camping trip!
Yeah!
Good memories!
Hopefully other than Pero.
Well, I'm sure you know, I don't think anything got in the way of you having fun!
The most fun you can have!
You bring a big fork so you can do this.
Yeah.
Just like this big thing.
That's gooey, it's okay.
He's lost it.
If it's gooey, you won't get food poisoning.
That's how it goes.
BAU BAU!
I don't know, that makes me want to have more summer fun, right?
Mashed Pero!
I don't know.
Pero poisoning?
This is different from BAU BAU, Biyou, okay?
Different.
You have to cook it well.
Exactly, exactly.
I can almost smell that picture though.
Right?
I want to do more things like that.
But we've already been having so much fun so I'm not complaining at all.
And a part of that fun has been because of...
Advent Anniversary!
Yeah!
I've been saying it almost every day, but right now it's the Summer of Advent!
And you know with our anniversary and everything, we had a wonderful collab all together!
We had poison gacha!
Yeah, we played for each other!
And I still taste natto and strawberries in my mouth, but that's a sign!
We had...
Advent's second original song premiere, Sirens!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Did you like it?
What did you think?
You listened, right?
Of course, right?
Many times over, right?
Sirens.
Not that many times.
I gotta do it many times because the sirens don't stop.
What's silence?
You know, it's a little bit different from rebellion.
How does it make you feel?
It makes me feel so BAU.
That's how it goes.
It makes you feel so BAU.
Yeah.
But, uh, silence is composed and written by James Lamdino and Morning!
It's me, it's my Morning!
Why?
It's so fancy!
And captivating!
I feel like, you know, you could just be like, uh,
Walking around a place with a whole bunch of like... In the... In the know!
People that are up to date!
You know, the fashionable people, the cool people.
And they'll be like, oh yeah, what's this cool song called?
Sirens.
Like hololive English -Advent-.
Yeah.
I wouldn't know, but... They know.
And that's good because... I'm singing!
It's a super stylish song!
I could see us walking down the tower.
The sirens, the sirens, the sirens.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
But you know, really really stylish.
Very repeatable song.
So I hope that...
Ruffians that you listen to lots and lots over.
It's a bit of a different style, right?
Yeah, a little bit more.
Different from Rebellion.
Yeah, Rebellion was very catchy.
Get your paws up in the air!
Dance and jump!
Yeah, and Sirens is like a... But sort of cool dance and jump.
You make me feel so low.
Kind of.
So long, you know.
Right, the MV was really cool, right?
Yeah!
Yeah, all the environments and then us, we were in the... It's so dream.
So dream.
Try to be cool.
Yeah.
You know, and especially, you know, we've never kind of sung a song like this or recorded a song like this.
So it's kind of a fun new challenge for us.
Oh no, yay.
That part's not- It shouldn't be that hard.
It shouldn't be that hard.
Because when we tried recording it's... Oh no, yay.
Oh no, yay.
Right.
It's just like... It can kind of do it, but it's like... It's not quite there.
Yeah.
Lots of, oh no, yeah.
Over and over and over and over.
Yeah.
That was taking place, that was all the time.
Not the time now.
This is FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
I did see a number of Ruffians being like, Fuwawa can sound like that!
Ruffians!
That's just me singing a song in karaoke.
I sing songs like that normally too.
I don't know what you're surprised about.
Have your ears been not working this whole time?
But I'm happy.
I'm really really so happy to be able to sing another original song together with Alice.
It took us a little while.
Have you noticed it?
I don't think I have not seen a single mention of this.
Once you hear it, you can't un-hear it.
Yeah.
Honest, that's the only thing- Moco-chan!
No hints!
They have to discover it!
I want a hint!
I want a- I want a hint.
No, no, no, no.
No hints!
I don't think anyone said anything!
I want to ruin it!
No, no, they have to discover it!
They have to discover it!
They have to discover it.
Listen more.
Okay!
BAU BAU!
You have to listen carefully, okay?
We have to repeat it a lot, okay?
There is also a special anniversary!
Look at the illustration we have!
BAU BAU.
A bunch of different things, but first we have a rubber mat!
The illustration's done by Marumoru-sensei!
Thank you!
Don't sneeze during the party, okay, Moco-chan?
But look, we're all having a party and Nerissa has a full cake just for you!
It's like, oh, you're an Adventrix?
Okay, you can buy a cake.
You have a full cake.
Yeah, Moco-chan!
I don't know, you're gripping that parfait there.
You're like, this is my parfait.
I'm not gonna let it go.
I'll let you have a bite.
And I'm about to take a bite of a strawberry.
So many sweets!
Ruffians, you know, maybe you want to have a rubber mat because if you sneeze on it, it's a little bit easier to clean, right?
They spill crepes and desserts.
Then you know, it's good.
And then, next!
We have the button badge with case.
It's not just like a normal button badge.
It has a case.
Yeah, so you can keep it nice and safe, and you know, this means that it'll look perfect with an ita bag.
You know, you have your ita bag, and then you're like, oh, I kind of want to put, like, something else on the outside.
Then you can do that, and maybe you're like, oh, I have a badge, a button badge I especially, especially like.
I want to keep it safe.
This is the perfect thing for that.
So.
I hope that maybe you think about that, especially if you like Maki Itabai.
Yeah!
Or you just like, you have a special badge that you really want to get.
Really like, I get that.
I get that too.
This is the perfect thing for that.
Yeah!
And not just that!
We also have the pin badge!
I feel like, you know, Rikuo has a pin badge.
Right!
Justice has a pin badge.
She's got a pin badge.
Here we go, we're one year late.
But that's okay because we can celebrate our first anniversary together!
We're one year late to the party.
It's our party.
Yeah.
But see, you could also put this advent pin that's on your itabag if you wanted to.
Yeah, and next, we have the motif keychain.
Yeah.
I really like ours, it's very cute.
I'm not sure, you know, we have little wings there.
But you could put the keychain on your keychain.
Right, you could.
With the keys.
Especially, you know, I'm sure it'd match very well with our half-anniversary keychains if you want to.
I really want one for keys, too.
BAU BAU!
And that is our anniversary celebration merch!
They're on sale right now, Ruffians!
So if you're interested, please check them out!
Sales end in September, so...
Let's make a decision sometime.
But!
I know we talked about it recently.
Yeah.
This is separate from our anniversary merch.
Which is coming out soon.
And it's gonna be a bit of a battle, I think.
Yeah, there's so many exciting things, you know.
Summertime!
Summer of Advent!
And you know, it's similar to our birthday merch.
Because it's stuff that we thought about and worked really hard to make!
So that, you know,
Ruffians!
So...
Don't get excited out, okay?
BAU BAU!
And also another part of the Summer of Advent.
We're taking over the Twitter.
We're taking over the Instagram.
As you know.
It's Advent.
Yeah, we're rebelling.
Yeah, with a bunch of photos of our activities we've been doing over the summer.
Behind the scenes, you know.
Yeah, look at us all at the airport where we picked up Shiori, Biboo, and Nerissa!
Just some casual clothes, because you know, it's the airport.
You don't get all dressed up for it.
But there'll be a lot more coming soon, so please look forward to them too!
And we're gonna take it over!
So look forward to seeing us on our off time.
BAU BAU!
But it's not just the summer of Advent!
No!
A senpai released a brand new song cover!
Yeah!
Kanata-senpai!
Kanata-senpai released a cover of Igaku!
A song by Kasane Teto!
Mocoboi!
She wrote it herself.
No!
Mocoboi is a pretty amazing boy.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, Kanata-senpai is such a good singer too.
There's so many senpai that are amazing at singing.
Oh, but speaking of senpai.
Oh!
We also did the... Anishina's Family Feast!
BAU BAU!
Thank you much!
That was chaotic, huh?
It was so much fun, right?
Yeah, I love Spelling.
You love Spelling?
I actually do like Spelling a lot.
But Ame-senpai, Gura-senpai, they prepared so much.
We became puppets!
And then we had to spell all of a sudden.
It was kind of funny because the words that they kept on giving us to spell kind of felt kind of...
Arranged.
I'm just happy I didn't get necessary.
Me too.
Yeah.
Necessary, I would be done.
That's one of the words I just can't spell.
Necessary, no.
Yeah.
I spelled it so poorly that spellcheck can't help me.
So... But it was a lot of fun.
We learned a lot about spelling.
Yeah!
I got to spell Sprinkle!
Ah!
Amoco-chan!
Pterodactyl!
You spelled Pterodactyl!
Yeah!
Ruffians as a side note, is it spelled or spelled?
I spelled the word.
It's an apple.
And I got to spell, you know there's words like restaurant.
People are always like, oh restaurant.
Restaurant.
R-E-S-T-E-R-A-U-N-T.
No, no, it's restaurant.
Restaurant.
I got to spell refrigerator.
Yes!
And you know refrigerator is kind of like that one too.
You spell it F-R-I-D-E-G-A-T-O-R.
Fridgerator.
You know, there's a lot of different things in the fridge.
The gated is the important part to spell refrigerator.
Hopefully there's stuff in the fridge.
Yeah.
And, wow.
Everyone was really really good at spelling.
I was doing well too.
So well that I ended up on fire.
But it was okay!
Because, well, we might not have won in the end, right Moco-chan?
No.
But, you know, Gigi took that.
Gigi took that, and she got all the spelling right.
Okay, Shiori.
Okay, okay.
Is that fancy?
But we wanted the L, Ruffians.
Because we made you, and I think you know, the most hololisters, smile!
And that's more important than the spelling.
You know!
This world is filled with a thing called spellcheck.
Spellcheck exists for a reason.
But is there a thing called smilecheck?
No!
I guess a doctor's kind of... A doctor-dentist is kind of a smilecheck.
No.
FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
We won!
We won the Fumi-summing L.E.B.
Wait, did you go to kisses?
Ruffians, if you think I asked for kisses, you think I won't get them?
That's true, we didn't ask Ame-senpai and Rina-senpai for kisses.
Right.
I guess, you know, maybe Gigi... Maybe that's like a good point.
A difficult thing for her.
I could just go... Ame-senpai... Can I have a kiss?
Ko-chan, if you added a BAU BAUer here, then it might help.
Ame-senpai!
Can I have a kiss?
Do you think she would like that?
I think she would.
Yeah, Gigi has to work hard.
FUWAMOCO, we can just ask.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Ame!
Ame would never refuse that right!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
From Kurina-senpai.
We don't need a kiss, but we do need to kinda munch on the tail.
Maybe not munch, but a slap?
A slap?
I feel like it'd be very gummy.
I would like to just... Ino-senpai's tail!
Tail.
Ah, arms.
They're arms, thank you.
I wanna eat those.
Gura-senpai's tail.
Probably very salty.
I could just get slapped by that.
It'd be like... Otsumami.
I wanna dry it out.
Otsumami!
BAU BAU!
If you keep on talking about food, the muffins are gonna get you more hungry.
Ruffians!
You know, we had some bad news with Pero.
But we have some good news!
FUWAMOCO, we just reached 900,000 subscribers on YouTube!
We're done, I'm V. V.
BAU BAU!
You know, FUWAMOCO on the DVD, we had a big goal of 1 million subscribers.
1 million subscribers by our first anniversary.
And you know, I kind of have a feeling that within
Two days?
We can't get to 1 million subs.
But that doesn't mean that we're gonna stop trying.
No.
And we're gonna continue to work hard until we reach that!
Until we reach that!
But you know, even though we had the goal of 1 million by our anniversary,
That's not everything.
Yeah.
You know, we've always said it's the journey that matters.
It's not the goal.
And it's a goal.
It's a lofty, big, big goal.
That's because we're hungry!
Yeah!
And we still have that goal.
So you know, even if we don't quite reach it in time, that doesn't mean that we're never gonna reach it.
No.
So, we're gonna continue to go on this journey together, you Ruffians!
That's how you should think about things too, okay Ruffians?
We're gonna do it the FUWAMOCO way, you know?
If we, you know, run and run and run and hurt ourselves and go kinda crazy trying to get to 1 million, that's not right.
No, it's the journey, so we're gonna continue on this journey together with you Ruffians!
You know, you aim for the moon, you end up in the stars, and that's exactly where we are with you Ruffians, so thank you so much!
I'll continue to do my best here!
Past our first year anniversary.
Past maybe 1 million subscribers.
And on and on and on.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I think we have a very cute doggy waiting for us.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Tyson!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah, and you know, even though he's 13, you know, maybe he's a little small, a little older.
He's fierce!
Tyson's fierce!
Fierce.
Yeah.
And I'm not quite sure, do you see that tree there?
In the back?
In the back there, you see how it's kind of like... Ouch!
There's a chunk missing.
You know, who did that?
Tyson.
He's responsible for that.
Very strong.
Fierce.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, how do you think Tyson BAU BAU?
Well, if he can take down a tree, then I... That's exactly what I was imagining too.
That's him taking down a tree.
But what if it was like a longer BAU, like a BAAA.
BAU BAU!
I think you know, we can both say that Taisen has been doing an amazing job at not just protecting this Ruffian's smile, but also this Ruffian's body.
And you know, I did such a good job at making this Ruffian feel safe.
Nothing scares Tyson, not even trees.
He'll take down the trees.
If there's any scary ones, you know, in the middle of the night.
I bet he'll even take down rocks too.
We don't know.
Don't tell Biboo.
BAU BAU!
Next Ruffian, where have those paws been going, huh?
Let's take a look at today.
I went on a walk.
We have dad.
It's a beautiful picture.
I didn't fall over the edge or anything right.
I hope that you enjoyed the fresh mountain and that it wasn't too hot out.
Just fresh, just fresh.
Fresh and cool, that's it.
Underneath the FUWAMOCO skies.
BAU BAU!
Please continue traveling, visiting things, but being safe, okay?
And our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Good day, FUWAMOCO!
Good day!
Q. If FUWAMOCO equals BAU BAU, Biboo equals ROCK RCOK, Nerissa equals OPE OPE, Shiori equals
Question question...
Wow.
You know, recently, Shiori kind of said something in repetition quite a bit.
And that's "THERE THERE".
THERE THERE!
"Oh, FUWAMOCO, there, there."
Yeah, I even have messages to Shiori being like... Shiori's like "there, there."
You know, when we were on our trip, I was trying to help, but...
Boog boog.
No.
Book book.
There there.
What's other things?
What's other things Shiori says?
Crazy stuff.
Snip snip.
No.
There there.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
I am so so certain that you want to be a part of FUWAMOCO Morning, right Ruffians?
Right.
You do, right?
You do.
As your part of FUWAMOCO Morning, just being here and commenting and cheering us on.
But you can be an even bigger part of FUWAMOCO Morning by using the hashtag FWMCMORNING and sending us your Doggie of the Day.
So what if you don't have a doggy?
I'm sure you have a question.
You can send us your question.
You can become the Question of the Day.
You know, going on a walk is always good.
Go on a walk, show us what you saw.
See something funny, take a photo.
Maybe you're even tidying up around the house and you see Pero, unfortunately.
Let us know, send us a photo, okay?
Just don't forget the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Okay, Ruffians!
You can be a big part, okay?
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have... De-den! ARK!
We're going to be continuing to play hololive ARK, the holo ARK, together with our senpai right now!
There's a special event going on with the game ARK.
It's the very first time, we just played it for the first time just a couple minutes ago together.
We are now mother to two dinosaurs and a buddy.
But we survived the raid somehow with the help of our wonderful senpai.
So we'll continue to do our best.
Unfortunately, this event you know, a lot of it's run by our JP senpai.
So naturally, it has
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru!
Well, you can pick really early or you can pick really late.
It's a countdown, right?
We wanted to spend the very first moment of our second year together with you.
I'm quitting time.
You know we wanted to talk about a bunch of different things and maybe talk with some...
Senpai we haven't been able to talk with before.
Also senpai we've only chatted with a little bit.
So we're really looking forward to it.
Ruffians!
Moi!
BAU BAU!
And!
Also take a look at our schedule!
Our anniversary!
It's on the 31st.
July 31st.
Starting we have, you know, we have FUWAMOCO Arc.
We have FUWAMOCO Morning.
But that's not just it!
That's not it.
We have our first anniversary celebration.
It starts at 10am PT.
10am JST or 6pm PT.
And you know, we're gonna be doing a bunch of different things.
You know.
What?
Some singing.
Some watching.
Reflecting.
Talking.
All the things that FUWAMOCO loves to do.
And then,
8.30pm PT.
We have another thing there.
But, I don't know, I think our file got corrupted.
It's kind of blurry.
Sorry about that.
But, I think this is kind of the most exciting thing.
I don't know, Ruffians, why do you think Foggs is the most exciting?
Please don't make me sad.
Moco-chan's gonna cry, okay, Ruffians?
Yeah.
Let it fog so much we couldn't play it any other time, okay?
So please join us for our first anniversary!
And then we'll also do some chatting, certainly after that at 8.45 p.m. PT, OK?
Yes!
And then you know we have a whole bunch of other things that are all really, really exciting, but!
Over on Shiori and Bebe's channel, they're making their 3D debut!
Yes!
You can't miss it, okay, Ruffians?
You just can't.
It's a huge deal, and we're looking forward to it so much, so please be there to celebrate this big 3D debut!
BAU BAU!
Are you supposed to be surprised about some hidden mysterious pixels?
Yes!
Because it's a mystery.
If there's a mystery, Ruffians, you have to be excited for the mystery.
Would've been more exciting if we were question, question, question like on it.
It's a mystery.
Mystery.
Yeah.
Well, FUWAMOFANS for joining us to the archive today!
Here is your FUWAMOCO word for the comments!
BAU BAU!
What?
Adventiversary!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Copper Chef!
Chef.
Copper Chef.
BAU BAU!
Dochi Dochi!
Sekinetsu.
BAU BAU!
Nyampo.
Exam.
BAU BAU!
P.Poi.
Pomejames.
BAU BAU!
Pokex.
Our destiny.
BAU BAU!
Kodoji kara toki?
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!